Petey I got the BJ's yeah wait till that
[ __ ] comes out man they should do it on
pay-per-view and they'd they pay off the
deficit that Trump PTA they could
pay-per-view that [ __ ] they could put it
up in Madison Square Garden on the big
screen and sell the place out 3 [ __ ]
wasn't that what is time are looking for
keep keep I'm a cording audio but video
they'll hear this so you guys cool with
us being out yeah ok
pressin let's do this felt like the
president's vindictive and hold against
us
readings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investment app that lets you buy and
sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos or
commission free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just a wealthy simple and intuitive with
a clear design with data presented and
an easy to digest way the reason I'm
talking about this is because Robin Hood
is giving the church family free stock
like Apple for the sprint to help build
your portfolio wouldn't this last time
anybody talked to you about your
portfolio uncle Joey's told me about
portfolio signup at Robin Hood calm
Church that's Church dot Robin Hood calm
sorry
church dot Robin Hood calm and they're
gonna give me a free stock like Apple
for the Sprint just to help you get
started alright this is courting the no
Commission fees are the broken jitters
charged up to $10 for every tenth trade
but Robin Hood doesn't charge Commission
fees trade stocks and you keep all your
profits so do me a favor go to church
that Robin Hood calm the church is also
brought to you by my mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz listen
tis the season to make gibbous ok [ __ ]
being jolly and it guineas to be jolly
and that's where my bookie comes in
remember who you're betting on is just
as important or who you're betting with
and that's why I always tell all you
[ __ ] sickos to bet with my bookie I
love your [ __ ]
now trust me guys then the
best bet for you this season they've
been in business for years they got
great reviews online and their mobile
site is nice and easy to use so do me a
favor go to my bookie calm right now and
deposit after 7 p.m. Eastern Time and
they'll give you an additional 24 hour
free play on deposits over 100 hours use
promo code Church to activate your offer
take this [ __ ] muley [ __ ]
tremendous well upgrade
are we gonna follow that having a fire
that jelly what the [ __ ] thing now
what is time we're looking for a [ __ ]
show what is he looking for I haven't
seen it I just saw the commercial for ya
jumps on the desk he's looking for a P
tape yeah and all the missing tape yeah
I thought I was looking for the N word
tape that's what Prentice from The
Apprentice all that [ __ ] what hurts and
more the end the N word tape getting out
of the P tape yeah now Pete a blood true
you know yeah they were talking about
something when we forget as a country is
that we've hated every president or less
since I came from Cuba you [ __ ]
behave in presence yeah
all right you hated Kennedy so much you
shot that [ __ ]
then you impeach Nixon whatever I mean
it I still remember the night he [ __ ]
was on TV I was a kid and that was
crying I really believed in America how
kind of press I didn't understand
Watergate understand none of that [ __ ]
but we were always crying we've never
been happier the only way we're happy is
if somebody brings us we want the
president that every day we wake up and
there's a check for $20 that's the only
president we want you just put your 20
in your mailbox every day unless it's
that we're always gonna cry or complain
about some so you're trying to figure
out listen dog if you put the [ __ ]
tape on in here all day
you just looked on a tape recorder in
here for a week but didn't you hear even
before the podcast or the podcast before
well you listen here at night you could
make millions listening to it yeah but
anybody who listens to it knows that
whatever is said isn't really coming
from the heart first of all you're
dealing
fifty percent with a comedian 50% of our
humor comes from comedy which comes from
the pain when I found my mother on the
floor and her arm was purple and I could
see that by the shoulder it was just
like you got hit with a train purple she
had a massive heart attack I cracked a
joke to myself so why would i crack a
joke about anything else
the most sacred thing in a man's life is
his mother and I'll never forget to
defuse that shock I crack like a [ __ ]
joke yeah like I cracked a joke to
myself why she'll never know I got left
back in the seventh grade I knew it like
just stupid [ __ ] yeah like I said that
we got a ping sent to us and read it
like a thing oh yeah and the guy said
that I made a joke about a Mexican
little boy crawling in the cage and then
you should have seen like 15 people some
enjoy forget seasonal immigrant I never
forgot I was an immigrant whoa comedians
what we say is the first effort when you
see something Greg Fitzsimmons that
first voice there your reaction that's
the reaction the audience wants to hear
hmm we just don't have the balls to say
it right I'll never forget 9/11 9/11 was
on a Tuesday morning and one day then I
was at the store and Paul Mooney was on
stage and it was the week that the black
guy was gonna break the homerun record
Barry Bonds sorry buds against the white
dude look I'm Mark McGwire Oh was it a
myself sir no no it was Mark McGwire and
the white dude going head ahead and I'm
the forget that then he opens up with
them never gonna let that [ __ ] break my
record like he just went off on a
tangent and he went off while it's so
deep but actually wanted somebody [ __ ]
subconscious okay like they're never
gonna let that [ __ ] hit a homerun
that's never gonna happen homie they're
gonna do something to make some that
[ __ ] whatever you know return so the
next morning I wake up to my wife going
oh my god oh my god my wife was really
like I had just gotten with it
she was overly emotional and I'm waking
up from a cocaine [ __ ] hangover and
I'm seeing the first time
I'll never forget laying back down beau
Moody was right they could break the
homerun record because it was like on
the Tuesday when he was gonna do it that
was the first thought that came to my
head yeah
then the second thought was the Giants
didn't cover last night uh-huh the
Giants did not cover the night before
and I go that's comedy that's what you
wanted to hear yeah well my dad died we
they had a priest come by and say a few
words but he handed out he panted out a
the prayer on a piece of paper to
everybody like a little like a little
missile at because they know half the
people are you know we're Irish Catholic
but this is this um there's some of the
the other tribes snuck in some of my
dad's friends were Jewish so they gave
him a gave them all a cheat sheet and we
say the prayer and then we're done the
priest goes okay if you could hand those
back into the front again I got it I go
he lived like it he died like he lived
sheep and uh and everybody started
laughing and the priest got [ __ ]
pissed and I was like good you should
get pissed collects in the [ __ ]
prayer reaction that's the reaction yeah
it's really weird that that's what
comedy is calmly is your first the first
thing you really sec to yourself yeah
that's the comedy and then that thought
your uh your smooth side whatever that
part of your brain comes in smoothes out
the joke you talk yourself out of doing
the joking stage that day but that first
one thing that comes to your mind
that's the joke they want to hear yeah
that takes you a long time cuz you know
what the balls to say it but that's the
truth he kept saying that [ __ ] gonna
hit the homerun he'll never gonna let
him hit the homerun and as soon as that
building down hit with the first plane
that's all I kept thinking about was he
was [ __ ] right cuz it was that night
when he was gonna do it that Tuesday
like yeah wait uh I was onstage last
Thursday night and I I did this joke I
just stupid new joke it wasn't like
anything I thought much about it's
probably not a joke I would've kept but
I just threw it out there cuz I had a
piece of paper with new bits written on
it and it was Thursday and I it was
[ __ ] twelve people there what was
this at the
improv and so I go and the joke was just
you know my nephew's complain and he
can't get any [ __ ] at college you know
I said well don't worry about it I got
this thing called the freshman 15
I go you find all those girls in the
spring you're good to go and this cursed
woman stands at middle-aged woman [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you with that fat shaming
misogynist dish but I mean Joey she went
zero to 60 she didn't she didn't ramp up
it the second I'd finished that joke she
was on her feet screaming the whole
crowd turns around looks at her like
what the [ __ ] is this a terrorist attack
and the bouncers come over and I'm
throwing gas on the fire cuz she's with
her two daughters I'm gone
look at mommy get drunk I go there I go
that's how you burn calories getting
that angry and they dragged her out
screaming and I have to fit onto another
ten minutes and the whole room is
[ __ ] awkward at this point so I I
joke about getting big laughs but then I
still got a eventually go back to my
material and so I come out front mmm and
I'm standing there talking uh Owen Smith
and a couple other people and well the
sudden a woman comes out again full head
of steam again [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
you're not funny I would never [ __ ] you
like that I go what are you talking
about and so I'm standing there and I'm
going back and forth with her until I
realize she's not de-escalating like her
pitch is staying at ten and I'm not
gonna stand on Melrose in front of the
Improv screen with this crazy lady for
any longer so I turn around I walk away
down the street to go to my car but
she's screaming at the back of my head
and I feel like a [ __ ] like I'm walking
away from her all the comics are
watching
I'm not even turning around I'm just
beelining back to my car and so same
thing I the next day it got tagged on
social media mine and she wrote this
[ __ ] letter the daughter wrote this
letter saying that I was a misogynist
when I said about her mom and Bill of
blood blew it all up and then of course
all the comments are like I would have
kicked his ass and huh all this [ __ ]
like nobody they weren't there they're
here at a crazy and so uh yes who was
the whole thing it was the whole thing
think of this thing that's going on
right now now but I could come out after
30 so she is and say that you choked to
the other party are you showed me a dick
what the where we go with this well we
this is what I was scared of this is the
first time that Iraq okay so now it's
not about what we did two years ago or
that I showed you my dick in the room
not like that now it's something that
happened so for dirty sushi is while I
was a judge you didn't say nothing and
there's already women [ __ ] say no
like don't even know the whole foot
nobody knows the whole story nobody was
there well I think that's a scary part
is that just because of the way things
are now is that not that they can't say
it but in everyone immediately goes
guilty and you can't really recover from
that so I don't have as much of a
problem with them coming out if he did
it if they didn't do it like I think
there should be a punishment if they
didn't do it and have some repercussions
for that but if he did it I don't have
much of a problem with that but I just
it's scary to think about like someone
could just say anything online and if
you get enough people behind you know no
matter what the truth is people are
always gonna like I just saw one comic
is gonna be in Boston it's pretty coming
up and they said coming back after
assault allegations even though it came
out that he didn't like it no he never
did another that's crazy
well here's the problem is that when
there's a movement there's momentum and
people get swept up into it and that can
be used for good that can be used for
bad in this case obviously it's for good
you know this movement is trying to help
women see that they would they should be
believed when they come out that we have
to not marginalize them right away
but then people get swept up in that and
they suddenly go oh this is part of that
as opposed to let's judge each case on
its own let's not say oh I'm already
riled up because you know there's been
all these cases that have been proven
about men abusing women so I'm already
angry and now let's grab this guy and
put him in that
that same energy as opposed to let's
look at this one individual case and try
to judge it by those merits this morning
I spoke to a friend of mine Joe Lucci
and I met Joe Lucci probably in the
eighth grade and they banned the area
where he lived was the wildest area in
my hometown there's five or six grammar
schools that grammar school by far takes
everybody away like they were doing [ __ ]
in the eighth grade that nobody was
doing in the town and everybody had to
catch up over the years like they were
the real deal at the field then just
have Lincoln school but they had the
field they had the rocks and the rock
they were on the rocks every night these
guys which meant they were out there
drinking smoking [ __ ] ghetto blasters
with music they were crazy you gonna
have for the morning of thought people
like if we live downtown we go let's cut
through 64th Street feel you'd find
eight [ __ ] tripping on acid I
mean that they were just deep and he
wasn't coming to the show to see you in
West Palm Beach and I'm bringing my wife
he goes should I bring my daughter's
what do you think and I go uh-oh she
wasn't to know that I Oh deed in your
backyard I was a junior in high school
now which was part like at six o'clock
at night his party was started like a
4:00 in the afternoon and I got there
like at 6:00 with a gram of blow I was
in high school and quaaludes but there
were the count of quaaludes so that's
when I started even the ones that people
making at home
yeah what's the table of crooked right
which means at the pump the the the
thing leaks into the bottom ones and
these day week yeah well the weak ones
first and then they eat the second one
and all I remember is waking up in an
alley at 4:00 in the morning with drool
of puke all over me and the next day
hearing the stories yeah how high school
kids a lot to be drinking and funding
obviously anyways but 4 p.m. don't like
when I did that we tried to hide it his
parents owned the bar home like oh is
that a bar his parents home the bar so
there was always they were always
the bar yeah so he would have parties in
his basement that was just legendary but
his legendary parties where we're before
concerts so I still remember going to
his house you ready for this children
august 4th of 1979 they would start at
4:00 you get that and be a chang of beer
and there'd be 12 guys and 12 girls or
20 girls or whatever the [ __ ] and people
were smoking snorting blow eating pills
and then and about 6:45 we'd walked the
Kennedy Boulevard take the bus into the
city and walk to Madison Square Garden
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up and go watch we went
the see ac/dc instead and he said all
that he goes that was a rough with
because I remember just Angus running
through the audience was on top of what
Evers
but then he we all had the same trait he
goes I started doing that tradition way
before anybody before concert like meet
at my house at 3:00 because the first
party had was Monday December 6 1976 and
he's my age so he had to be [ __ ]
started he was 10 not 10 13 and he was I
went to see black Ted Nugent hoping for
Black Sabbath when he released
free-for-all tour and he goes guess what
else happened that night the Cleveland
Browns beat Thor whatever and Monday
Night Football I mean that's how good is
memory and wise yeah but I was just
thinking about how could you judge me
from that night well you can't judge
somebody from what they did dirty is all
I'd be under the prison yeah but drugs
is different than holding down a woman
against her will trying to take her
clothes off you know that stays with her
that's thing her memory of that night is
gonna be a lot more clear because for a
woman to be attacked like that is
traumatic and that stays with them and
it [ __ ] it [ __ ] up their heads that
why wouldn't a woman wake up the next
morning and contact the authorities or
contacts in life well because this older
for 30 years I mean the whole thing
about holding it in that
long is it's a mystery to a lot of
people but I think the reality of coming
out as a teenage girl at a time when you
you're you're embarrassed you got a zit
you're trying to cover that zit on the
way to school you don't want to be
noticed you don't want to be the center
of attention and you're and you're
raised to respect people that are older
than you so you take [ __ ] for granted if
it's an older person there's a lot of
there's a lot of reasons why a girl that
age is one freshman year at college
I came home to the dorms my firt it was
my first week in school and I came home
we were snorting crank because that's
what this kid from Philly came to school
with I never I never heard a crank in my
life so snorting and drinking tequila
and then we go out to these parties and
we come back to the dorm and now it's
like two o'clock in the morning 3
o'clock in the morning and I see this
girl and she's walking up the steps of
the dorm and she's got her arms around
two friends and she's crying
hysterically and I go what the [ __ ]
happened and I said well she just got
sexually assaulted by this guy I go well
where is he
they said he took off he's you know he's
wearing a bell Bellevue middle school
hoodie sweatshirt and I remember what it
said but it was something really
specific so I'm staying here with this
other kid Jeff and I didn't know Jeff
I'd never met him before we went on to
become close friends still still friends
them to this day I met him that night
and and so they described this
sweatshirt we go to Comm Ave basically
be use campus is built on one Avenue
it's not round it's a straight line so
we get to Comm Ave and we're in the
middle of it so I go right I'll go up
you go down let's find this guy so I run
up and sure enough I'm you know I'm five
foot eight 150 pounds of course I come
on the guy and the guy is a football
player and he's with a buddy who's a
football player but he's got the
sweatshirt on and I said hey they want
to talk to you back at Sleeper dorm and
and we have a couple words and his
friend comes over he knocks me down and
then they take off just you know cocky
sown out of a sprint just a jog away
from me and I'm on the ground I find a
very fine fruit punch bottles and I
smash in half and I chased these guys up
the street and they cut into Hamilton
house which was a dorm about two blocks
away
and they go in but the dorm the security
guard there's like there's a there's a
lobby and to get through the door which
is bulletproof glass that guy's got a
buzz you in so he's about to buzz him in
I come running in with the bottle I go
these guys are wanted on the other
campus for rape so god hasn't buzzed
them in two guys turn on me they come at
me I hold up the bottle I say I say the
guy call the cops he calls the cops for
it takes about four minutes and I got
these two football players and I got a
bottle and I got him and the cops show
up and they they take statements from
everybody and everybody goes home and I
got I get a call from the head of the
dorms about four days later saying that
this this these guys are pressing
charges on me for assault with a deadly
weapon and that the girl who got
assaulted she's not pressing charges
because she is her freshman year it's
the first week of school she's been
she's been taking SAT prep courses it's
taken AP classes in high school all
leading up to this experience college is
her first week and she decides I don't
want to spend my freshman year in a
courtroom I don't want to get taken
apart by the prosecution I don't want to
you know whatever and she wasn't raped
like penetration but she was assaulted
which means yeah I I don't know could
mean could mean a lot of different
things but I mean she wasn't penetrated
so not that that means anything but
she's a type do you reason I say that is
because I was thinking about rape kit
and there wouldn't have been a rape kit
in this case so she didn't have to under
undergo that so I say to her look you
gotta you gotta press charges on these
guys so we we did that she leveraged it
she goes well if they don't dress if
they don't drop the charges on Greg I'm
pressing charges on on that guy for
assault so it all came out in the wash
they dropped the charges she dropped the
charge we went on but it made me think
at that time you don't put yourself in
the reality of a woman is up against
when she's got to press charges and what
what else is going on in her life that
would give her the flexibility and
strength and the independent
from everything else in her life to be
able to follow that that track and it
might not have been a time for her at
the time this out but she's at Yale you
know this other girl she was a Puerto
Rican girl at Yale that was what half of
1% of the population
she was low income she was there on
scholarship she already felt like she
didn't fit in everybody else at Yale is
wearing [ __ ] corduroy blazes with
leather patches on the elbows and pipes
and here she is this Puerto Rican girl
probably wearing Sassoon jeans in a
halter top she doesn't know how to fit
in and now she's gonna press charges on
a guy who's Cavanaugh this guy who's a
made man his father went here his
grandfather went here you know said she
sat on a barrio this is a reality on
college campuses right cuz I used to
hear about little things in Boulder that
would wait I wasn't the prior to
investigator but I would just hear
things yeah you know you just heard
little things that this fraternity was
kind of crooked or whatever you know
girls pass out they run trains by image
right hey that was never really looked
at I didn't understand that whole thing
yeah there was a girl in my hometown
that they called marathon woman there
was there was his family the Denny's the
Denny's we'll [ __ ] up family but thank
God for them I got my license here
earlier I got my driver's license when I
was 16 but he's on their IDs no because
they hunka hold the driving school
okay so for like 50 bucks you go home
you have a bus - 117 you got a license
but the one of them was a guitar player
and he acted he did everything like
Jimmy Page and he got some [ __ ]
groupie chick and you roll up roll up on
him but he wasn't a bad kid yeah hey kid
hey what's up you know he's one of the
few kids of the early seventies that had
a log game of my babe oh yeah and he
would ask you you want to get your dick
sucked
yeah she'll suck your dick and I was
like scared of all that stuff at that eh
so I just avoided how old were you gonna
be 40 and 15 when I first
then Jimmy had a bit maybe 12 but I got
all that still hanging out with Jimmy's
brother my mother died I started hanging
out with Jimmy's brother who people
would pull me aside and go why are you
hanging out with the devil yeah and I
liked him because he was the devil but
after he wrecks I think I wanna go
because he double-crossed you every deal
yeah you always got double-crossed he
was just a bag of ice but it was an
experience but his brother would take
that chick to like the house party go
everybody wanted dicks up we would go
yet and she'd go in the room and he
would send guys in one would know we pay
$2 why'd she do it she just liked it she
just liked it there's a thousand
different various she did one night she
blew 18 guys the other night she moved
21 she did that thing twice and would go
to high school next day Jesus said she
would sit the ruler class the guys the
back would go marathon woman mammoth I
would as she wouldn't turn around it was
and even now thinking back I still him
what a face look like and you could tell
it was something that right with her
sadness there was something no no no it
was something that right were like she
was a um yeah yeah something wasn't
right
Jesus that's a that's a sad story and
that she graduated she was a year older
I'm a mushy I was like a Julia when she
went off I was a sophomore yeah my
mother died sophomore year I was a
sophomore with the rumors of her started
coming up and then one day we went to
school there was everywhere
yeah like [ __ ] born 18 guys and came up
burped he said who's next you know I'm
saying like that type of [ __ ] Jesus and
I spoke to somebody recently they asked
me do you remember that night I wasn't
that I wasn't there I heard about it
both times that she went off I was at a
party somewhere else uptown
both times is downtown cuz Mike Danny
live downtown they were downtown family
like do you imagine well this girl who
Cavanaugh and his buddies had all they'd
all tagged in their yearbook
there was some what was
name a pride or alumni it was a first
name we can't pray was it anyway Iran
with eight because they had a little
rhyme about if you can't get a date it's
never too late
call up pray it was it prayed something
like that and uh and so so they they all
had in their year but it was something
like fifteen guys that all had her name
in their yearbook quotes as like a
conquest rn8 RNA and ATP Nate and and
here's this woman she's what is she in
her 50s how old's Cavan out fifty
something yeah she's in her 50s she's
living suburban Connecticut she's got
two and a half kids a Volvo and all the
sudden this is coming out in the
national papers that she was the woman
to conquer in high school
thirty years before she was one of the
women who supported him on on Joey
Cavanaugh and in said and would like
sign the letter like oh he was he always
treated me with respect
right and then the yearbook comes out
yeah do you I mean Greg you have older
kids do you feel like with pumpkin blame
porn how crazy it's gone like that kids
no more stuff now or did you guys know
just as much when you were growing up oh
[ __ ] I didn't know [ __ ] yeah I didn't
know [ __ ] I had a couple magazines and I
remember the first time I saw a porn
movie I was at my buddy my my Colombian
buddy David Aaron current him and his
brother Hector they lived above a bodega
on Cortland Street in New York New York
had projects our Terry town where I grew
up at projects downtown because we had a
GM plant and there was a big Cuban
Colombian black neighborhood downtown
and he lived in the middle of it it was
it was actually really [ __ ] it was
dangerous we used to get robbed all the
time and so we're sitting in his
apartment and Hector comes in and me and
David are maybe maybe 13 12 probably
more like 12 and Hector's likes he's
already like 18 and he's already he's
already done some time for for cocaine
bringing cocaine and from Miami and so
he shows us a porno movie on a real
- real that's what that's what the
original yeah no what year was this say
t1 yeah
reel-to-reel and so we're sitting there
watching it and I got a chubby and he
starts laughing he starts grabbing it
he's grabbed my dick and I'm watching
these two women go down on each other
with the muffs more hair than [ __ ] oh
you have Joey on your hands oh it's
scary it's going at it and noise the
jazz band little cut some good funk not
that shitty they're back in the Sabac in
the 70s late 70s 80s that's a good [ __ ]
yeah by the guitar right right and I
kept grab my dick and I was like what
you know what I didn't think it was gay
or weird or anything that I was like you
ever have an experience that just sort
of gets bottled up in your brain and you
don't open that bottle again for like 20
or 30 years and then you open it up you
go oh oh that was [ __ ] up that was
wrong what he was doing he showed me
that porn for a reason let me ask you
this would you if he was running for
governor today yeah would you call a
brain and [ __ ] Pharaoh and say guess
what one day he showed me a pole and he
touched my dick of my dick got off no
because I didn't feel victimized by it
and it didn't scar me there was no
trauma
did you look there's a joke like I got
pulled over what I got in the guys car
one day and he went to touch he asked me
if I liked basket why the basket more
betrayed my legs yeah and he hit the
ball but he grabbed my dick yeah and at
the next light the [ __ ] door opened
by itself God God had just showed me
like what I got myself into now he's
gonna get me out of it but don't ever do
it again
and I ran away and I got the guy's
license plate number the next day I told
a few of my friends and if we saw that
license plate we're gonna [ __ ] him up
yeah but that but that's the point you
had the power to do that even though it
in that moment you were disempowered you
still had your boys and you still there
would have been retribution on your end
that would have been satisfying but for
a teenage girl
it is the system's not in her favor you
know and so and I think with this guy I
didn't feel
I didn't feel that violated because AI
didn't attach any sexuality to it on his
end I just thought he was [ __ ] around
and maybe he was but looking back on it
the odds are showing a 12 year old a
porn movie and grabbing his grab his TV
he was like 18 maybe 19 so but but it's
different I think I don't know I don't
know I think I was introduced just right
now I can say a thousand bad things
which are honest I loved my godfather my
Godfather's are the best Catholic
Godfather's you could have have when
you're Catholic and you're cubed with
somebody baptizes you it's not our white
people act like you don't see those
people again yeah
the Cubans hold that very sacred right
they come to the house every week and
they talk to you and I still don't know
my godmother and him and her I had a
divorce they had a bet
I had a pick that was forced to pick a
side of my god father used to drove me
50s take me to the movies but one of the
things he did was he would take me to
his white girlfriends houses and he
would not [ __ ] them in front of me but I
don't know when I was like eight one
time we went over there he goes I want
to show you so it was to check eating
each other up when you're ready would
see me say something sexual to me here
you still piss wheat in Spanish that
means he did are you coming yeah yeah he
would just say little things to me to
prep me for women uh-huh so but so when
I was 11 or 12 I was already prepped
yeah but I was so adopted they so
indoctrinated and the Catholic religion
that it was against everything I had
like to take my dick down touch a girl's
see that shame about it I know you were
ready to go yeah I was a prude I was
always always a prude like I talk a lot
of [ __ ] and get my first [ __ ] too
late because I thought it for will be
sucked a dick she was just disgusting
like at that age and it was disgusting
but there wasn't there wasn't it's a
when I was about in the seventh grade or
eighth grade there was an incident with
night where
my high school teachers played the Mets
my faculty from North Bergen played
against the Mets in a celebrity charity
basketball game and the place was packed
I was with the kids from downtown
Juan Perez these this other group of kid
Peter Jimenez Julian he was dead now all
these guys on the way out there was a
girl I mean there was it was a school
auditorium you know well it was antinea
and there was a girl everybody was
grabbing the tits I got one point she
was like covered up and people were just
like grabbing the tits or grabbing her
ass that she was like turning around and
I even think I grabbed the tattoo and I
was really young I remember I got really
like my dick got hard and my face got
red and I remember that it started off
as a joke with this girl like they were
saying she was given free squeezes or
something but then it was like 300 guys
on the top like it was really ugly we
walked home and then always thought
about how bad that girl felt my gosh she
was older than us if we were the 7th
grade maybe she was in high school yeah
you know I saw years later and she was
still crazy but that time she had [ __ ]
50 guys so yeah she had no credibility
or she would attacked anybody but that
was wrong that was wrong thinking back
now 50 years later that I think that was
wrong you know who the [ __ ] know who
the [ __ ] knows what they're doing
why Cosby got three years today yeah 3 3
to 10 years really that means that mean
so year and a half that's a year that
could be ain't here
that's a year and a half he's got a tons
of buddy yeah and he's gonna claim that
he's six will you put you in the
hospital truly not jail and then you got
special privileges and he gets a TV he's
never gonna to what he did in my world
is just [ __ ] terrible 60 women named
after him and that's just what those are
just the ones that came forward that's
just the ones that came full triple that
there's triple that that said you know
we don't want to deal with it we don't
want to have this wound yeah you know
take a go to somebody's house from
waking up on the couch they go what
happened ah we were [ __ ] around we're
the start you know like we just ate an
animal don't worry about it you'll be
fine which did happen to you a couple
times two men we just left Jorge Perez
on the couch just left above the couch
Sarah Tiana I helped her over to the
couch and put it down put a blanket on
just never came back yeah got up walk
that they see no he won't give her money
and the next thing you know he was
getting chased out of her mind he's
often Twitter hey hey with Ali's Jones
and start the web page together
[ __ ] did he get thrown off Twitter a
while ago yeah he could before Alex
Jones I mean I remember watching his
videos and they were they were [ __ ]
they were bent he was he was losing his
mind he gets mad when people say stuff
like that
apparently oh yeah I mean who knows that
maybe uh I don't think it's fake but
it's you think he believes all that
stuff I don't know it seems like it who
what does he believe he's a super right
wing there's a lot of like all right
kind of stuff you know conspiratorial
[ __ ] and uh just but I don't know I
don't want to speak I shouldn't speak
about it I opened my mouth before I
should have cuz cuz he you know he's a
friend
yeah we're talking about edibles out
yeah he was fine he was red stars I saw
him like stretching his neck and [ __ ]
yeah like he was doing something weird
also he goes do you mind if I take a
walk and that's it yeah well he never
came back
hey and we spoke briefly the next days I
mean I just started walking and then fix
you know we play these movements of a
month yeah right that star changed his
whole world just to put him to changes
well your whole we were talking before
the podcast about Greg's producer who
produces XM radio is a good producer and
forgot to press record because you gave
him something I don't know what you gave
him
but [ __ ] I mean it was like it was like
Mardi Gras you
throwing those gummy bears around like
we're a bunch of [ __ ] frat guys
it's but everything she pitches Shiba
cheap cheese that's a class those other
bulls all even acid that's what they
make up for like acid really cheap achoo
let me tell you something let me tell
you this and you could say whatever you
want or whatever number one I would have
been dead right now if I would have done
asked after my mom died but it was real
acid when people were getting real acid
and opened up your mind
it really did as dumb as dis [ __ ]
sounds but smoking marijuana over its up
your mind if you smoke about it's like
if you don't smoke matter what like weak
for example you started smoking in the
morning yeah put the iPad oh whatever
iPad speakers of music and you went for
a walk
you'd be surprised the thoughts that
come in to add that's why I always
enjoyed marijuana
I enjoyed marijuana from the beginning
because now I had somebody a handsome
truth but I think in some ways marijuana
it's not necessarily that it gives you
the thoughts is it quiets all the other
thoughts so you can hear the one that
was down there in the first place that's
what I loved about I loved like that's
why I don't even drink when I smoke pot
I always just settled on retha because I
didn't like the effect alcohol added to
it alcohol added ooh yelling screaming
effect to it I don't like that I just
want to smoke enjoyed and put it on now
yeah don't ask me those questions that
has no beating to it cuz I'm a [ __ ] I'd
much rather listen to the what's the
last time you put on an album and just
sat transfixed what album it had to be
about three weeks ago I came in here one
night
I was home all week like we did the
podcast in two nights and I didn't have
a spot fight three nights I came in the
end and it had to be 10 o'clock
I knew Lee was at the fourth wall he
wasn't gonna stop by and I put on for
the first time okay we listened to parts
of it on the radio for the first time
I listen to both sides back to back
smoking Ponte it and it [ __ ]
destroyed be a big Floyd dark silent
yeah my first CD yeah like just
listening to the whole out both sides
made me realize I got out my comedy game
yeah because this was the fourth of five
bass two pieces in a row that's never
been good did they have five five albums
that good
I think it's metal wish you were here
animals animals Dark Side of the Moon at
the end with the wall Wow
alright original order yeah that is that
is five thank you for the fun great
albums battle and I put wish you were
here animals dark side of a wall and it
ends with the wall Dark Side of the Moon
ends with the wall that's for world
class yeah those more specials that even
you got up a delivery we gave you the
standing ovation
yeah definitely so whatever the [ __ ]
your platforms gonna pay fifteen studio
albums yeah did they really crazy damn
yeah and the electronics that were going
on in the wall all kinds of like
precursors for the music we're listening
to today well the music will listen to
today is lacking a lot of things I think
it's it's more costumey yeah the music
did you see that thing yesterday Ace
Frehley will be your best man for six
thousand dollars the chapel in Vegas in
reality Sheriff rail from October 26 of
the 28 if you get married a kiss into
Vegas for 6 grand Hillary a berry and
walk her down the aisle
I'll be your best man and then sing 2
songs via I was thinking of the split
that with somebody and getting like a
gay marriage and have an Ace Frehley be
my [ __ ] how funny would that be
married any Bravo endanger in full
makeup with full makeup kiss me no no no
he's he looks like a bus hit him yeah
you know people think that
I really believe that if you do with
drugs at your 60s keep going yeah don't
stop over like I stopped at 44 but if
you're over 50 once you stop doing drugs
you look worse
yeah worse just keep going yeah just he
looks [ __ ] like a bus at a but I
loved that I think he's one of the
funniest people of this planet yeah Ace
Frehley yeah one on one when he's high
and [ __ ] on interviews I [ __ ] laugh
mine he's from the Bronx yeah so he's
got that little accent he's got that
attitude I crack up all the time I watch
the interview today I would have thought
he was dead for the first two minutes of
it because I know he was sitting there
going what the [ __ ] am i doing
yeah life yeah I got this [ __ ] kid
asking me about too hot to handle his
alive and all this [ __ ] but for six
grand he'll be your best minute
[ __ ] I'd do it I'd be someone's best man
after six grand that's exactly the
number as a matter of fact no less no
more yeah but then you got to put up
with the wedding there you go
now be your best man if you pay me six
grand I walk it walk it hug you take a
picture we've yeah yeah no there's no
wedding I got that done good sure cause
20 yeah 25 hey get up and get up on
stage yeah that's 52 the $50,000 I
[ __ ] hate weddings
yeah yeah do you remember in your 20s
love and weddings oh I do
no no no number one I'm CUBAN yeah
explain these people have a thing called
quinceaneras yeah they come from 8:00 in
the morning till [ __ ] midnight I know
what they have to do it with just 15 16
and I was one of the only Cubans ever
I knew that went to a [ __ ] sick
insane yeah I signed up the girl asked
me to be one of the guys that the tuxedo
is the whole thing and I [ __ ] went
there in an hour in I faked thought I
was sick yeah I left and I never went to
a quinceañera or anything yet and my
mom's friends would beg me my mom would
really tell her not the billion [ __ ]
yeah and then my stepdad had a daughter
I went to her wedding
well that was a kid that was a kid I
didn't know what a what it was about I
had an okay time but that [ __ ] wedding
will you have to take up airplane for
somebody
oh yeah that's where it is then you show
up and they got a table number you don't
even get to choose he simply the woods
her ID I made that mistake in 1987 I
went back for a wedding in Jersey you
know it cost me [ __ ] a tonight now
Jenelle this fight didn't have yeah I
love to bat you like what the [ __ ] am i
doing I could support a hundred the
envelope and live my [ __ ] life I
actually went back there and I hated the
whole experience like now weddings to me
have become annoying yes it's annoying
yeah and the war was wadis with the
board oi yes yeah cuz nobody relaxes
yeah nobody relaxes yeah but the worse
though is you buy that plane ticket you
buy that hotel room you you put the
money in the envelope and then they sit
then they give you a nut I'm 32 all
right I'm a table 32 you sit there and
you got the second cousin of the love
the bride you don't know the bride now
you're sitting with her second cousin
your friends are all sitting on the
other room they got the good day well
you got the [ __ ] one so for all this
money I can't even have the freedom to
talk to who I want to talk to it this
[ __ ] reception that's crazy so I
don't know I like that I like weddings
that are just just parties the wedding I
went to Jersey if there was a hundred
people at the wedding
eighty four would do a blow at the
reception yeah so the cake nobody was
touching
Doby even thought of eating the meal
everybody still had [ __ ] roast beef
and half a chicken on the table so
everybody was sweating everybody had
that dance floor was [ __ ] yeah I had
never seen definitely them yeah there
was a line at the bathroom all the
conversations with the bathroom that was
the wedding of 87 a little bit sitting
there going
and the families like the old people
were siblings yeah all the bathroom yeah
everybody haven't been going into the
bathroom and there was a thousand drinks
which draws them like everywhere the
men's bathroom toilets because Diane
just going to this boy drinks there are
they still married nope oh my god they
got the voice 10 years later they're
long gone but that's the wedding where I
saw that with the coat she was there no
the guy that got married over the
carwash
yeah he told me that Whitney Houston
would love it when they would sweep the
back of a car would be empty Bendel's
yeah but she would take bindles and
throw them in the backseat I'm like not
only is this a bad wedding but these
guys are lying to me yeah doesn't look
okay yeah I'll say who else had a badass
wedding you know who else had a badass
well he'll the first time I got married
was one of the [ __ ] craziest things
cuz I got out of prison I got into
prison in February and I knocked her up
in April and I mean I was smart I was
doing everything with three hands it's
like nothing had happened and I've been
a halfway house
so my goal was to get out laughs way out
so we set the wedding for nine nine of
89
that was the wedding date the
anniversary just fell a couple days ago
we would have been buried on 20 somebody
29 years a little bit married and she
got whole family on her side was in that
I was clean and sober that changed my
life and they had a weekend pass of the
judge so they couldn't piss me till
Wednesday legally so I knew I was gonna
go [ __ ] an AWOL off the reservation so
we get to the church my brothers flying
and he's gonna be the best man but he
ain't get up till wedding the night
before he went to a wedding the night
before and got on the red-eye in came to
Colorado and when he walked in I had a
couple my friends come in when he walked
in the priest pulled me aside the priest
goes I don't know if he know what I did
before I was here I worked with drug
addicts and said
sisqó your best bid that's not gonna
work today
he's got rings around his know something
before thanks how [ __ ] up he was so
another friend of mine Georgie had to
step in and be my best man but Mike was
in the back [ __ ] habit yeah he was
the guy that would sue everybody I had a
friend that would well the Seward spree
he teamed up with this Jew lawyer and
there would you suing people what after
the other he got tons of money he got
one because he was carrying the tub up a
thing and the tub got cut he got one
stitch the guy got him 200 Lord his Jew
was a [ __ ] Savage
he got him another one and then he got
his wife one because she was walking
down the street with groceries and the
kid was on a bicycle on the side of the
street she was on the sidewalk this is
how good this Jew was as an attorney and
a car cutting the bike off the bike went
into the sidewalk to hit my friends and
she felt there nothing happened he got
her like 80,000 because she sued the
property over all about having a fence
yeah yeah might make it the way big
cocaine he's like I got 8,000 in my
pocket and I got about four working you
know the saying that means he had four
lawsuits working there was suing people
he was getting commissions the guy's
name was cozy Co zzi of the forget that
though you need money go see cuz he just
goes see him and then he'll come out
like this yeah did you fall attach
meaning yeah it was like he was
tremendous but I'll never forget he was
loaded
Mike was loaded at the time we get
married at st. Sacred Heart Church and
now we got to go to this courtyard
barriers for the reception but the brass
has played Colorado that day one of
those big games if my buddy's a
degenerate gambler so soon as we get the
reception he goes right up to my wife's
family he's like where's the TV
they're like TV there's no TVs here
these guys he brought my three of his
friends well the body brought two of his
friends they probably had an answer
between we were in the bathroom with my
wife's brother she had two brothers but
one of the brothers Joe King was crazy
we were they was like a blizzard in
there we were split with three hands
I was crying at the wedding I had
[ __ ] my nose was leaking that my wife
knew I was doing blow she was the poor
girl is like trying to play it off yeah
but what broke the wedding wasn't my
buddy's like I'm serious I need a TV do
it there's no TVs here he read to the
room he went to room he took the TV from
the room brought it downstairs
we gave the stock clerk 20 bucks of
extension cord my wife did the
photographer get up I think I looked all
those pictures up did he win money that
night a little [ __ ] at the end he was
higher than them I handed up his
daughter just have cancer that's why
these just had cancer she beat at 80 but
that's who helped me out when I got back
into Connolly and it was weird because
when I moved back I moved back to Jersey
in 93 I was just starting to get
momentum as an open mic and I stayed
with him and his wife his wife was
pregnant and he would go out seven
nights a week and get [ __ ] up he would
get [ __ ] up and he would go I'm paying
you to stay at my wife and his wife and
B would get Chinese through the Secaucus
there was a place that was open till
2:00 every minute 11:00 we get $50 worth
Chinese food egg rolls fried cream were
ran tunes whatever [ __ ] called rankin
rangoon we would destroy that [ __ ]
thing
so he she was pregnant he smoked pot she
was gonna smoke power the dog yeah what
the [ __ ] just smoke a little bit and she
would smoke a little bit with the baby
was born they had to keep her in the
hospital for an extra day just a baby it
was [ __ ] up the baby but she's alright
Jesus got married a month ago in
Colorado and she beat cancer younger
sister Alexa was the one that had the
wheat that when I got stoned there's a
baby yeah
as a fetus as a fetus the younger one
had the kids at Lindsay which people
from the church helped out so I said
well he took GoFundMe she beat it you
know that dead embryo sucking on that
umbilical cord it's got the munchies
sucking the marrow let me tell you
something I can't imagine yeah I would
receive frankly we would smoke through
the 70s oh yeah [ __ ] oh yeah they didn't
give a [ __ ] yeah that's that [ __ ] just
started maybe 15 years ago I remember
seeing a picture my mom's full belly
full a baby and I'm one of the green
creme de menthe
remember those funny she used to drink
those that was her drink Creve the boost
and their whole in a bright green
drinking are at a certain point weren't
weren't doctors saying like cigarettes
are good for you like nananana ten
doctors recommend Campbell I'm pretty
sure that at one point they said it was
healthy I don't [ __ ] think so they
just did no look I got a bit when you
were able ister have you been in a plane
recently where they still have ashtrays
oh yeah yeah they still have extras
exactly what the hell does this [ __ ]
place yeah take a beat in a plane being
able to smoke I still remember yes in
the back yeah I said the back the back
people would be [ __ ] spawn yeah like
nothing happened yeah I don't remember
that but I remember going to restaurants
as a kid and there was a smoking section
non-smoking section
my dad used to smoke three packs a day
my mom smoked a pack a day and we would
drive we do this in New York where it's
cold you got the windows up six months
to a year and
just chain-smoking just sit in the back
height asthma - I would I be having like
an asthma attacks and so he cracked the
window to give me some air just to crack
and then he would fly remember he would
flick the cigarette at the crack you
know like like somehow it was magically
sucking the ash out it was blowing it in
the backseat so not only we inhaling
look it's well recovered ashes I really
didn't give a [ __ ] now now it was such a
different [ __ ] world
yeah just it lately I've been bored you
know I have playdates with the baby and
stuff like that and I'll tell you what I
see a lot I see kids that like playing
inside the house this is the third play
date that I've been on that the people
have huge yards I got a huge yard I
throw her out every day their yard I
throw her out the yard I want to make
the plane for the house every day for at
least a half hour I took her up there
yesterday we looked at [ __ ] flowers
for the house those things that you blow
dandelion sandy was just to get them
because I'm sick and tired of it we are
programming a couple boats around with a
beautiful house Cuban people pool [ __ ]
Jacuzzi huge honor I'm sitting there
watching these parents talking while the
kids are running in the [ __ ] house
there's [ __ ] expensive lamps you know
the whole thing and they're running in
the house and I'm [ __ ] you know I
can't relax I can't relax this I smell
the accident come let's see how the
blood it doesn't take a look at Jeanne's
yeah you know there's eight kids running
in the [ __ ] house
and I had it [ __ ] like I hadn't go
back there no mercy get out like get
outside and all the kids will go but
havin a good time you know what I
finally told my wife I go you gotta help
out too you got it you're out there
sitting in this kid's gonna get hurt
wouldn't it you gotta come an answer to
me cuz I know what you're doing you're
sitting down talking with these women
with these kids are running but this
last week I went to a playdate sadly and
again guy had a huge backyard with a
[ __ ] trampoline
they went out there for five minutes and
right away the kids feel like I want to
go inside and they have a huge living
room and they're playing soccer in this
glass everywhere and Mercy's our mule
mercy from playing soccer that's just
one if Melissa could do anything is kick
a [ __ ] ball
she was kicking even the people like
Jesus Christ and I'm like guys I think
it's time to go outside
yeah and the kids like well I don't
wanna go outside of the parents like
well he doesn't want to go outside let's
force him outside let's force him to go
outside you know let's force them to get
some [ __ ] vitamin D that's why these
kids don't go out I've noticed it lately
they don't go out I don't want my
daughter you know my daughter is only
allowed to be on the computer ten
minutes you know that right but my
wife's got about the Nazi program with
the timer and everything ten minutes a
day but it's at night and tablets when
she gets home from school that's it
because she doesn't work that that word
that's great I don't want to get
involved in that world and by the way
well well this subject here I don't live
on social media I check it
do you know say yeah like it every three
or four hours I check social media so
I'll go home and check Twitter if I'm
out like I don't have facebook on my
phone so you could face me to your blue
with the [ __ ] face I don't know what
you're talking to me Facebook yeah yeah
I haven't should I check it twice a year
I don't have facebook on my phone are
you get on facebook for 2-3 minutes I
promote yeah I answer some email but I
don't check it all day long
yeah and the same thing with Twitter I
don't know on Twitter all day long I
check it and I move on with my life
there are people that I read that
[ __ ] constantly constantly you
look to see it who's tweeting Kate Kate
Quigley is constantly tweeting deed
dowry how do I have a [ __ ] has to
turn the vegan it's a bad [ __ ] habit
Rogan I spoke to him last night he goes
I asked him how the hunting trip went
because I had a really good time because
you know the best part of the hunting
trip was there was no into the death
week I know what kind of whatever the
jab the first few hours because the
first day was a little rough after that
it was smooth
it was great to give it a [ __ ]
breather yeah guys do me a favor Scott
Cunningham the whole [ __ ] Facebook
group all you guys I love you to death
but stop go outside go do salted yeah
these guys are around there
all [ __ ] day talking about [ __ ] but
at the end of the week it doesn't matter
I know and I see comics like that and I
see him at the club and they got no new
material they're doing the same [ __ ] I
look at them like you know you could
have spent all that [ __ ] time does
this we're gonna your act at this time
for this there's a toy it's like I was
telling Lee that when I was 27 walked up
a black guy of the kitchen made a
comment to me we were told we could I
have like insomnia one day we're talking
because you know think about all this
[ __ ] you spend your energy on hood
that's bad did they even of thinking I
think if you took that energy and
expanded into something good and ever
since that statement with him I looked
at everything a lot differently I love
football I love football but I don't
have eight hours to watch football prior
to that I don't know forget I could sit
in Colorado especially in Aspen from the
seasons from November 18th to maybe
March 15th and then from Joe Bay there's
nothing going on in Aspen like if you
live in Aspen only the locals will work
and they closed the restaurants the ski
shops are closed everything's closed and
everybody goes away
I would stay you know why I was Stanley
because I would get up at 8:00 in the
morning and get a bong even my
girlfriend would go back to her parents
house and visit them in Boulder and I
would stay in that house all [ __ ] day
watching movies like I could stay there
all day go for movie with VHS I could
sit watch six movies and one day and
watch one movie twice and I would get up
to go to the bathroom eat but I would
have I would do that three days a week
now [ __ ] watch movies every [ __ ]
movie
you think when I worked at that video
store I would go there and take ten
movies no port they had everything
that's what the 16 year old was sucking
Vic was to Traci Lords yeah that's the
Tracy Lord was huge yeah the octopus in
a [ __ ] huh huh Tracy does Japan yeah
Tracy does Tokyo she put an octopus is a
[ __ ] like imma have to push wing one of
the [ __ ] just one not only not always
yeah no that's a [ __ ] that's a visit
right there they all had a condom on a
sec sorry man you should develop the
octopus octopus and put a different
women yeah the end up like [ __ ] judge
Kerouac over here throw you in jail
merry-go-round almost yeah between the
be sure they would then tell the story
about the ice I was out with this gay
bar rant brunch certain nights like I
didn't know everything they had a
different feedback and would that I
would have a like one thing it was piss
on somebody night like Spit on somebody
might be good morning pub but I wanted
me at one time and there was a guy and
they were playing like Wheel of Fortune
it wasn't called wheel of fortune was
called like spin the [ __ ] the guy would
they would tie him up make expecting
claim Jesus but spread his legs on a
wheel on a wheel and if he won the
ballot or whatever they would make him
go upside down in so many seconds he was
upside down I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] dude looking for a grab a
blow me and my buddies like that was the
last resort to get blow and we went in
there and everybody was around this like
you know cherry go go go go
and I bet the bar like they ever be
gonna grab a blow he doesn't hold on
five minutes oh you didn't know cuz he
was gay as [ __ ] this guy his name was
Joe gashing is you think though it's I
need a wheel with [ __ ] button or
whatever so I go with this poor bastard
was upside down and this [ __ ] Puerto
Rican little
it's up that pipe but I figure like this
type of [ __ ] you're supposed to see that
with u8 but here's the thing here's
thing I understand about Joey Diaz and
the church what's happening in general
if I had one story that good you would
know I had that story because I would
have told I would have already told a
thirty time this is one of Betty yes
what I'm saying
but I thought about it and I thought
about one thing I'll never forget that
he was sucking the guy's dick and I was
behind all these gay guys it's bankrupt
bankrupt you got to eat his [ __ ] no I
don't know I don't know the guy's upside
down he's yelling cuz the Bloods in his
head so this guy's suck his dick don't
forget something baby go around look at
what the guy what looked like that was
sucking his dick and he was sucking it
you understand me we all the blood goes
to you head gets hard
this guy had both his cheeks connected
by using I thought family would think I
got my dick sucked but that's pretty
interesting guys that guy sucking for
his life he was sucking for his [ __ ]
why he got my coke and nobody what
happens are funny at least one time he
had to wait for his coke another way for
the coke brothers will watch what's
going on what's going on with the talent
you know I'm saying maybe I won't jump
in I would love to get my dick sucked if
I was upside down I think I got a panic
attack thinking back like if my head is
underneath I don't care how hot she is
if she just sucking my dick well it's a
race between passing out and coming is
that what it is yeah
I think I think you hear about these
people that are excess fixie
themselves while they masturbate and
I've always thought you know I've
masturbated for a lot of years and I'm
good but could I take it to another
level
no but I'm afraid what if I did and and
I and I forgot to let go of my neck or
whatever that's that's not the way you
want to okay so let the guy for me like
sex he goes into a room I think he's in
a closet he put put put his belt around
his neck you put your belt around your
neck and you hold the wood and pick your
weight up well you just choke yourself I
think you have to tie it off because you
got how David Carradine one of the
Caribbean brothers died doing that and
then Robin Williams supposedly my wrong
so let's go back here so it's like
suicide why are you jerking off you try
to choke yourself you know how when
you're getting choked out you get
lightheaded and phoric yeah so I guess
you combine that with masturbation and
it takes to me masturbation after all
these years is still so [ __ ] good
like I don't I don't picture making it
better it's like it's all in my control
it's joy it's a release as a little
shame afterwards but the actual
experience of it I still can't believe
after all these years there's nothing
that I still enjoy as much as that one
activity and there's nothing else close
you know when it comes to me I like
banging one out but I'm banging them out
of the road
yeah quick in the shower in the shower
like I love banging one out of the
shower when I could lay down and sit and
I got time like a dish in my hair I
shave you laid out in the shower I love
that [ __ ]
I hope for years I laid out of the
shower to me it's if when I get off a
plane that's the thing I look most
forward to when I land and I especially
at a hotel that's wrong when I go to
these fancy-schmancy old town yeah I'll
have a shower curtain yeah it's out yeah
they pissed me off
I turned the hot water on I [ __ ] smoke
a half a number sometimes I'll take a
little piece of his antics and I just
sit down water they [ __ ] think I wait
till it gets hot nice and steamy 20
minutes in you shave it's like shaving
through butter
yeah you know how long in there for
altogether
sometimes two hours the [ __ ] room
the shower here you get a call from the
from Greenpeace about know what's the
whole time I say it's up with South
poets shower is where the brick ends
yeah all the way to there yeah you walk
in you open of the thing they have a
sink in the shower and then they have a
gun and then they have a shower and then
they have water that comes out of the
walls and they have a little bench you
know many times I've gotten up there
before the boiler roll the [ __ ] joint
smoke they've gotten toasted because I
pay the 250 fine there I don't give a
[ __ ] because by the tiny it's just a big
room I'll pay I'll smoke a joint the
bathroom I'm sitting there from 4 to
6:30 you know cuz you can hear that
shower go he has a big room in yeah but
you but you used to do that when you
were big right you used to sleep in
there I love when I have the sleep apnea
I realized that the only way I could
fall asleep is if I was on an angle yeah
and you know you go to these people's
houses they're rich and you would take a
shower with somebody Rich's house 1.8
million two million dollars left at ten
minutes I got no hot water
you got a waste of the house yeah you
got your house is a waste yeah
minutes like I gotta wait another half
hour for the water get out you got beat
hey I lived in a building in Hollywood
do they have one of those old tanks do
you know I used to sleep with it you
keep the water running why you slept
because I feel it went to sleep when I
had to sleep apnoea I was 400 pounds so
I was going the tub I take a pillow and
I put a garbage bag on it
one of those [ __ ] hefty hefty hefty
FB would be with you would I
I would [ __ ] closed off the pillow I
would put it behind me I would put the
hot water in and it would hit like my
stomach hmm I just [ __ ] sleep there
when I wake up the paint will be peeling
off the wall before we moved there we
had to paint the bathroom I filled the
primer off the wall
sheetrock was coming off Maul the
[ __ ] top was just bald yeah you can
see where he's just dripped with brown
mould every time he would paint that the
mobile comes right through when I [ __ ]
the first got diagnosed with sleep apnea
it's the only way I could sleep I love
showers yeah I've always loved showers I
don't understand
dirty people whatsoever do you take
baths no I don't want to bathe in the
same water the germs that came when I
wanted to stop the flush okay I want to
sit bats bats is something right
drinking for me like in the 70s when you
watch the TV show Greg walked in here in
the 70s I would turn around and have a
bar with a bottle filled with a brown
booze and could be scotch bourbon
whiskey you don't know but you didn't
have the balls to ask I poured too over
Glen just gave it to you that was the
70s that's what we learned from home
even though I'm go with this
conversation
but path Oh bats bats has always been
something else that seemed overrated you
obviously you see some people in TV they
take a bath was it their whole world
change they get it there with bubbles a
day they said yeah yeah yeah they close
their eyes they're people either having
a good time yeah that's - but it's what
action I will continue war but what
about a jacuzzi tub that sounds like the
answer for you the water come on I don't
want to face water hit me on the titties
of my stomach I sit in the back I'll
just sit there with one leg up like a
thinker yeah I'll just go ahead clear my
head
you know we wear out the [ __ ] well we
reservoir in that town till well we were
going through a drought here in that way
you couldn't take showers and then live
next to hippies well they're done Hudson
I live next to hippies so I would take
showers there with yellow there's
water restriction I'd go [ __ ] yeah so
now I could you know abuse the water at
La I would take six seven bit of showers
yeah but will then go on the road that's
the first thing I do when I get off a
plane listen you ever wait to get on the
plane you see what comes off that plane
it's a jungle [ __ ] fever if somebody
from every different country breathing
something [ __ ] out
well there's a [ __ ] travel ban Lee
just made an audible from your face you
guys I'm not trying to be racist or a
bad person but look at all the people
are coming off that plane all national
and all the different countries they
came in from waiting that plane is one
big German then we just have to land a
plane because people got off the plane
coffin Philadelphia these international
fights I'm not lying to you before how
do you now let me ask you a question
Greg Fitzsimmons just so people know
home of that line have you ever seen the
last person get off oh it's yeah how
long till they start board oh but it's
yeah definitely the spray Lysol was the
fun I know they're waiting by the tie if
you're if you board from the back of the
plane by the time you get to the tenth
row that Army has already they've
already been on they've already cleared
the first ten rows they're worried by
the time five minutes later that thing
is gone the only thing they got time to
do is steal your [ __ ] because I have
left about a half a dozen things on
planes in the last few years
laptop computer a phone couple hats nice
hats nothing ever gets returned and I
always fill out the action those people
are [ __ ] they're thieves I granted
they're probably being underpaid
whatever but that shouldn't make you a
thief you know they got the bag the
garbage bag they take your computer they
put it inside they hold onto it and then
they and then they sell it later well
they have that TSA guy who had like a
house full of iPads oh no [ __ ] that was
he a couple years ago really yeah yeah I
don't trust planes just because the fact
that life saw the plane down and at
least the first-class get that wipes and
wipe down the headrest yeah I don't know
what this guy's [ __ ] hair is been hey
I don't know I don't know what the [ __ ]
maybe he was at that [ __ ] gay bar
last night getting his dick sucked
and his hair was touching totally powned
the sperm from babies don't [ __ ] it
though what about that TV screen you
know they have to touch to order stuff
all that stuff all that stuff I bring
handy why should be yeah my wife got me
a thing handy wipes I'd put it on the
behind are you really
oh yeah man I wipe down my [ __ ]
handles when I get off a plane there's
one thing for me to do and then take a
shower soon as I got off that plane I
got it my yuba whether it's gone water
covered when I get home on Sundays my
kids are already gone they were Church
my wife is at church already so I'm
walking in at 9:30 I unloaded everything
I put what belongs in my office in the
office I put the laundry away I stripped
down naked and then going that [ __ ]
put in that shower will i scrub tub rub
everything comes off then I take the
homecoming [ __ ] because always [ __ ]
before the show because no I do take the
homecoming [ __ ] before I don't like the
40 inch [ __ ] bang because the whole week
in your [ __ ] isn't a custom for the
toilet so it's embarrassed yeah the only
let sound like eight inch dump so four
inches little Cuban cigars you're like
what the [ __ ] what's going on my system
let me K so this is my answer hits the
one oh yeah down a little big need Oh
from the 405 to the 101 and I blast that
one fart and the [ __ ] and that uber
and I gotta up the width of the uber
drivers talking [ __ ] down they come
the phone to his cousin and I blast that
[ __ ] pre fart that last blast of
three [ __ ] days of the air on the
road your body's not used to that as
soon as I walk in I just drop my luggage
go to the bathroom and it's like a
40-inch yeah just comes a girl breaks in
half you break they break the surface of
the water that's a victory it looks like
a question mark sometimes a really took
a [ __ ] my bad luck I took a picture of
the Thompson Center to me a couple weeks
ago you can't unsee that [ __ ] yeah you
can I don't know cuz that people said
you should know if it's a good wood you
got is like if it breaks in half and
looks like a cane that's broken what the
one I said him with anything
yes
yeah it was really skinny yeah longer
than [ __ ] it was like the hemorrhoid
yeah
tap dead solution put a dent in it it's
like when you shoot a bullet you could
tell what gun it belongs there if
somebody looks at that [ __ ] like this
can't bother Joey Diaz his ass it's got
the mark a bug a bug [ __ ] I had to text
in like three or four times so it
stopped showing up on the in the window
and I don't even see it I'd sound like
two days later you didn't say a word I
must have missed ejecta and open my god
what's unbelievable is when you uh it's
so long that the head of it goes down
down the drain I like that down the tube
so you're only seeing it it's like a
it's like a iceberg you're only seeing
the top the body you already clogged up
the the pipe and then you get a swirl
going on a real soft thin one you can
get a swirl going that keeps sneaking
and you think I don't think I was
rotating my pelvis on that but that is a
perfect curl and it's about you know
1,800 degrees and a curl
Benji yogurt type yes I will go to bed
cheese and then alas and then when you
clip it and you look down and you broke
the water that's that's a that's a
celebration so what I like is the one
web sitting there and I gotta push it
for a couple minutes and then it feels
like I can feel my [ __ ] and
constrictive yeah I could feel actually
a goal like you're about to give birth
yes and so I always gotta go and I look
down it's like a [ __ ] it's like a
22-inch in the middle it's got my to
look like it looks like a snake that
ain't like a two words
it's got like a lump in the front they
look at the back oh my god those are
some redness I like the ones that come
out clean like yeah they call it a white
flag I think cuz on the wife you get
down on intelligence level on the
podcast this afternoon if you're if
you're photographing it that means you
gotta take the toilet paper after you
wipe and you got to try to drop it in
front of it or behind it so you get a
clean shot of the [ __ ] like what did you
do when you sent that picture to lay I
just took it to the but where's the
toilet paper and in the photograph I
don't
I didn't either are you too why
sometimes sometimes it's clean just
wiping how do you know because you wipe
it along the first wipe if you get if
you get a white sheet you walk away no I
wait a couple of minutes because there's
always a by the way you get the car
leaves yeah you spray a spicy yeah like
it has a little bird to it did you go
over here for toilet paper this little
piece of [ __ ] yeah so I always wipe it
and then give it a few minutes that's
why I have a door of my bathroom to the
outside and I smoke pot because mic off
whatever is stuck in there come on the
same time so you give me credit come on
see you in 10 years welcome brother walk
hey cash is good for you the whole time
I had been doing it since [ __ ] they
moved in for this spring like a bathroom
bong like they have the squatty potty
that helps you should make like a
smoking kit for the bathroom hey no cuz
everytime when I smoke that's what I do
I get off that plane I put my [ __ ] away
they go in that bathroom I upload the
back I can't imagine I always save a dog
or the best weed I took yeah so I don't
have to go right to the weed store
there's always we'd wait for me on
Sunday yeah I [ __ ] blast that off
bulb the shower I'm good for Sunday on
the Icarus I just can't imagine I'm
trying to picture Joey Diaz and and
again I don't I don't want to picture
your ass but I'm picturing your ass
taking a 22-inch dump and followed by
one wipe that frightens me sometimes
sometimes that's like that's like the
the [ __ ] you know that's like a ship
going down you send out you send out one
life preserver after it sometimes I take
toilet paper to take a rip of it and put
it down first so when the [ __ ] lands it
goes black easy yeah what yeah yeah I do
that so much more professionally I do
that so what you let you lay a base for
it to land on
yeah it doesn't splash me you make a
mess like a little runway like it looks
sort of plain those where the lid and
pull the runway the [ __ ] sees are the
dips are right there so when you're
flush it goes down even easier
gotta clean the bathroom view somebody's
house in a hotel that's right it's kids
courtesy it's a courtesy move this is a
gentleman do I've never I've heard early
8000 [ __ ] stories I've never heard of
laying down until that's why the
churches here so you can always learn
see the church is not about house of
these we want you to take something home
with you that you learned something you
know I learned this today on the church
I don't know if you put paper down first
it goes down the rabbit hole lot easier
just don't yeah it's the lessons that
are learned it is like it's like an
after-school special you always walk
away feeling a little moved in a little
inform I never do that story about you
know about college that's that's
something that stays with you for life
yeah you know I don't drink and drive
I just I refuse I barely smoked pot
drive I don't mind drinking the drive it
you know what when I was 18 I saw an
rx-7 [ __ ] hit a pole and I heard the
girl yelling inside yeah my boyfriend's
dead get me and the jaws of life and the
fireman was on top of a car cut and you
could see the blood on the windshield
and I made a mental note that was PTSD
for me that's like you know hey I didn't
look at it from I haven't really looked
at it from that perspective the last
couple weeks
I think because you haven't hold the
daughter you look at it from that
perspective the shock value you know I
give thanks every day I give thanks to
the Lord for let me live to be 55 I give
thanks to being at this point my career
but I give thanks for my mother died
that I didn't get taken in by animals
yeah like I could look you in the eye
and tell you as a man that anybody I had
caught that was in those days nothing
had to do with a sexual thing that
[ __ ] with me in my head right I'm very
fortunate I was around with jibt
American sido and nobody took me in to
[ __ ] molest me or do crazy but I
couldn't imagine the afterburner effect
of it you know it's like Joe asked me
one time do you ever have a girlfriend
that killed herself something like oh I
know I would kill myself I suck my own
dick
it was only if I do I suck my disgusting
dick I would kill myself but that's just
me being honest you know
so you're shocked that any girl that
suck your dick as is not yet
suicidal no no I'll just show you that
you would be surprised or they all have
a kind of a ego if they seem okay
there's like a little bit of a faraway
look in their eyes like there's
something there not quite over yet
there's something that they've seen
that's messy they can't unsee or taste I
saw a girl about ten years ago that I
had dated for a while you know we would
get high and I'll never forget that one
then I saw her at the store or something
it she was key give me right over that
time I had a girlfriend I had no
intention I'm banging her she was just
drunk and she was you know she was
taunting me to go up stock she was
testing me to see her my love these were
yeah and before she got a car she looked
at me she goes you know what I've always
thought about that I lift your balls and
she got out of a car slam the door this
is not disgusting Bennett she was gonna
happen it sucked my dick and lick my
balls usually like my fault
good night I guess the nights over I
wasn't even looking for a looki could be
nothing she was drunk and shoot she's
dead but fine you're not coming up to
have a night chaplain like no I'm going
on you know I don't drink and drive and
she's like fine then and she was getting
out she looked at me she goes you know
you know I've always thought about the
daily basis but I licked your disgusting
balls at one time but she slammed the
door whatever whatever whatever drives
you through life I you [ __ ] - it was no
[ __ ] cream of the crop I am saying a
couple lines about me this [ __ ]
Eastern fact that [ __ ] thing I wake
up with a [ __ ] roll in my mouth and
I'm staying with a butter drawing I eat
a girl with time that I could see the
chlamydia juice no stop it like a drip
drive and I see this little like like
Lisa X chin after a banya tacos but
you're looking chlamydia juice
who gives a [ __ ] we having a good time
you gotta fly chase with you I'm
surprised you never flying your neck
tonight you filthy [ __ ] this is a PEC
fly this guy's the only guy who's got a
pen fly flies and follow all the time
fly around his neck all the time he'd
sup when he leaves the door open he know
he knows I need to fly the fly oh come
and sit on his lap he's over there pad
look like a [ __ ] sight he says he's
got a service this guy I got service
flies that little bathroom I take shits
yeah yeah hey which bath the bathroom
boy yeah I have a back bathroom
connected to my office they could open
the door to take a [ __ ] there and it's
funny that the only place you [ __ ] in
the house yeah cuz I'm just coughs
controversy anyway he's the other battle
isn't between mercy of my wife's room
I'll [ __ ] that backdoor book yeah and
the other bathroom is outside of Mercy's
door and it's just too small like I feel
claustrophobic in there I can't move
this - too much [ __ ] going on this - I
can't share with this toys this like a
little black bow looking at she's hungry
to take a [ __ ] now you want to see I
want to see an Ace Frehley bobblehead
doll
Luce yeah I like their legs outward yep
I take a leg out of the pants dear
oh [ __ ] yeah I want to be loose I don't
whitehead you're gonna put your [ __ ] up
money with your handcuffs on their legs
why would you do that to yourself I take
this [ __ ] I take the legs out of the
pants I open up those two legs like I
have [ __ ] hole before wait that too if
you look at it here because you're
looking for dick to the people like a
catcher I take the leg eyelets see so
there's no mess understand so my [ __ ]
is imperfect like what the Koreans are
gonna send the Bissell you know that
thing moves over just like that
I'm position don't look the [ __ ]
thing and once I sit I can't get up
pants if you get up my ass sticks to the
toilet seat my nutsack Oh going to the
toilet Dan I'll sit on it you know many
times because I don't put my balls in
the toilet I don't do that because I was
like woman no I don't sit all the way
back I put my balls over I take toilet
paper and put on the toilet seat oh I
see Joey I've never heard of anybody
putting their balls on a toilet seat my
life Ellis I don't want I don't want my
wife to like a thousand set of balls if
she leaves my balls I've been doing this
as I was single I don't want a woman
looking bad balls so I'll put toilet
paper down and put my nutsack another
but if I get up yeah look if I get up
just flush or something yeah sometimes
the toilet seat sticks on my nutsack to
my leg skin that my nuts go under the
toilets you know me times I smashed my
nuts on the toilet seat because I got up
for yeah more than once
oh I have now I hold them now after
years I hold them when I get up to do
anything and I sit back there yeah I
have a whole process so wait you're at
the floor the toilet trying to tell my
brother how come so that instead of
taking you see you see those containers
a weed yeah those are all do so start
throwing them away what I do is I have
these flies they get caught in the
bathroom yeah if they get caught like a
glass
they get all [ __ ] [ __ ] you ever
see a fly where they were the glass by
the Sun yeah they get like then the
vision is lost
so they started getting close to me so I
take one of those cans I leave the dust
of it from the weed then take the fly
out hit my oh I'll just capture and I
think like a wing off then I put them in
there now close them in there and I'll
put holes on top of the [ __ ] thing
it's like a breathe and I just leave in
this like an experimental weave for
three or four days just the corners so
gonna be flies on an island they don't
want to go nowhere ways anymore no I'll
have one way they can still fly part
time do the thing it's a one-way trip
take a lot of laughs oh my god you have
no idea how much fun I had with those
flies like you gotta be there for it
where the Flies live a week letterman
let them have a good half a life I take
a little Starbucks Coffee stick gonna
take a little piece of [ __ ] we're gonna
feed it to just to keep my you [ __ ] I
it's like a THC love but please call
those chocolate bars and nuts around
them they give away on Christmas with
the truffles so they're getting a little
weed truffle they get [ __ ] wrapped up
with a little weed but I think you're
[ __ ] crazy
it was a Hannibal Lecter feeding the
girl in the well that's my therapist
about this now where do you get the [ __ ]
that's not your [ __ ] no I borrow for the
guy next door yeah it's my jelly thing I
go next door knock on his door you
thinking [ __ ] yet let me [ __ ] scoop
some up and you take your [ __ ] and you
take that test yet with your 50 where
you think of a piece of [ __ ] mail is
Starbuck sticks you're gonna start with
the woods yeah the same one you use to
cut the [ __ ] put it for the doctor yeah
why don't you catch it you have that's
not fair I don't want to catch it
they want good you'll be [ __ ] it's like
given them this is grass-fed reefer this
is free-range I'm eating chicken from
Kansas City that's big kick to the cage
I take care of my flies the best berries
[ __ ]
they gotta be strong yeah and then I
gotta be weed for two days there was
like three flies I turned over the [ __ ]
was gone there was a little THC best
left they just lived up my calendar for
like four days I went away I came back
there's one left I don't know what
happened three to uplet's talked about
you have like you should go in that
guy's house
yeah good times get good [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] that's what I wanted to I
want to get the word out or don't go
that main thing is to tell their friends
don't go in there the guys [ __ ]
medieval he put me in a [ __ ] he was
like the black guy from pulp fiction he
got four hard cracking pipe
[ __ ] to come over he go
medieval on yes and I always take one of
their wigs off I always say well their
wigs are just a lot of militant bosses
and then I gotta wash my hands eighteen
times this is the disgusting flat
they've borne out of [ __ ] oh yeah oh
yeah
that's nasty yeah we used to have
cockroaches in college freshman year the
the dorm rooms because all the kids were
drinking beer and we wanted to get the
five cents back so you'd keep you have
three cases of beer cans or bottles in
your room yes
stashed under your desk under the bed
and the cockroaches would come and
that's like a super food for cockroach
beer they love that [ __ ]
and so there was so many on the dresser
I would take a cup from the cafeteria
clear a clear cup and I put the roaches
underneath it I catch some throat under
and there would be like a deathmatch
would be like eight or ten cockroaches
and they would they would they would
start eating each other
after a while and it was they would they
would lock off and then one would die
and they'd all eat the body then another
one who'd die and they attack each other
and I was entertainment for us for a
year how would you catch the roaches in
you just grab them and then you slide
them under the cup oh well so you put
the cup over yeah and then you just put
them into the jar yeah how big will the
roaches be no not what about big you
know like I would say half the size your
pinky I don't know what it is what since
I was a kid I hated flies
I [ __ ] hate if why I've been killing
flies for fifty five [ __ ] years
yeah hate flies I'm good at it too yeah
with kids with flies I catch I can catch
the big ones I could small ones they're
tough I can catch him also okay I know
how do I know how to be able them my
kind of way [ __ ] them up a little bit he
has to just clap them and they're still
alive because if you smack them the [ __ ]
comes out of the back of the debt then
yeah well you're not gonna be able just
to smack them and I know exactly how to
do it I [ __ ] ate flies but well you
know the key is they say to come up
directly behind them they can't see
behind them so when they're sitting on
the counter take your hand flat and just
move it slowly and you can literally get
you can get within an inch of that fly
and then once you're there
they say CK yeah but they said they have
sensors they sense movement movement so
you got to move so slow they don't
notice you coming up and then once
you're there you just you just you know
you have to move your hand that fast
just close just close it as you move in
their direction you got it and then I
slam it on the ground till they get
dizzy and then I pick them up and take
them outside I don't know if a lot of
people don't especially from the church
in a little while you've been writing
yeah yeah and then a [ __ ] regular
show but a hit show crashing crashing
yeah yeah last day it's it been for
three I did the second in the third
season and you know I but I've been
right ever since my son was born
so like 16 years I've been writing on
shows almost every year like I usually I
get my I get a job I make sure I make
enough where I got my health coverage
for the year
so I can go talk to a shrink so I can
get some shots in my ass whatever I need
it's taken care of by the Writers Guild
she's gonna make sure I work a certain
amount of months and every year I get it
but just these past two years have been
much more full-time you know like the
show this show is like we work a couple
months in LA and then we go to New York
like three and a half months so with
that let you do the beginning of the
right yeah we write the scripts we pitch
the ideas you know it's a lot of comics
and we sit in a room Ian Ian Edwards has
been a part of it the last couple years
and Jamie Lee and you know Pete Holmes
and so we sit in a room we all just tell
Road stories just like what's the most
twisted [ __ ] that happened you on the
road but you know waitress that you
hooked up with at the back at the condo
or a club owner that [ __ ] you over and
you just tell these stories and then
they they just get put on cards up on
the wall and then later on we're trying
to figure out episodes and we pull from
those and it's really weird because you
see like like this past season that was
a story right out of my act that we
ended up shooting not on my act out of
my life does something had happened to
me on the road and I pitched it out all
sudden you know you're shooting it with
actors and you're like this is [ __ ]
trippy you know and but you but I think
it's uh it's the best way to write for
me is like just stories it's tough to
sit in a room and I've written on shows
where the characters are prefab it's
like those houses you buy and then they
move them to the site and they plop them
down that's what the scripts feel like
like this what the network likes they
want they want four characters workplace
you know these two are dating and
there's so many rules that but uh me
write the script is no creativity left
and with a show like this it all starts
from just stories and so you sit around
you tell a good story and then you don't
have to stop down the thing about HBO or
Amazon or Netflix is you don't first of
all you can curse you can show sex
whatever second of all you don't get
notes from the network HBO does not send
notes we shoot the show you know if they
if we get notes it's minimal very
minimal and they say we trust you with
Judd Apatow do your thing and then at
the end of it lock up give us the keys
we'll let you know if you can do another
season that's it and then we also don't
have commercial breaks so one of the
things about sitcoms it's so hard is
that there's two commercial breaks so
you've got to have two cliffhangers in
every episode you gotta have twice where
you got the audience where you side we
got to give them something that they're
gonna sit through a [ __ ] a Matthew
McConaughey ad for car and a watch
commercial and of mr.clean commercial
and and and so it falsely puts things
into the story it build up the stakes so
you got to deal with that so if you're
not dealing with that dynamic or notes
from the network then you can actually
write stories that flow I like the show
I will at first watch
the first season it took a couple
episodes for me to fall in love with it
because it brought me back to my open
mic in 93 when I was walking around New
York there was no barking yet there was
no barking but you still had a sell
tickets for people to come to your show
yeah so they would like uh was they
Lucifer / Lucien hawlucha Napoleonic
strip will give you 20 tickets to sell
for 40 bucks and you kept winning you
gave them 20 they never got that 20 for
me I just sold the tickets and kept the
money depending on how many tickets you
sold you get stage time like that was my
thing you know you guys did an episode
where he started dating the girl when
they went to Mecca right and she did
well and he did that's the he did well
she did well was she didn't yeah
and it was the it was a great episode
for me because it was like that's why
you don't date a comic yeah but these
are lessons where you know they the
comic you know you haven't do a warm-up
work which it just took the comic
through different levels for a guy like
me I enjoy
I watched it every Sunday when it came
on yeah because we do the podcast at
8:00 so we get to show it like 6:30 a.m.
in California yeah yeah like the one
show time to believe in I like them both
I'm dying up here yeah I like them both
but well one's a drama and one's a
comedy so they're different enough you
know and I think the tone is very
different with their show I think
there's a lot more stakes about success
whereas with Pete it's as much about his
journey as a person leaving the
Christian faith and getting exposed to
kind of this dark this darker world and
his transition out of that and having
relationships for the first time so I
think in this past season is probably
more about career than the other ones
were because he was still getting his
footing I think personally in the first
two our first two seasons it's it's a
weird place to be where Pete is on this
show yeah that's a weird place to be as
a comic you're in the middle of that
world you know and you have to have this
certain certain humblest to you you have
to you know keep your mouth shut keep
you ears open you know you guys have
them golf
couch to couch for a while the funny
thing is the human hardy perspective
yeah which I always thought Artie should
have been a lot bigger with him and
scale like when I first started kind of
me having any recurrence while of deal
that still speak to Rick he's a writer
also here or he rides from Robin white
and my first couple experiences on the
road when it was just like a like an
endless like I don't think I'm gonna
what he talking about like the first
time I cuz I beat my house at 4:00 to
pick me up pick you up I got there he's
like alright Park you call via would
taking my truck up you're driving I
can't drive I got three duis and then
first stop is at the liquor store if he
goes and he comes out he takes out half
a Gatorade and puts the whole thing of
vodka there and then we had a stop with
his coke dealers house and he came out
of the car it's fine you know it's 40
and he's like alright get on the
interstate and you're learning about his
car and he's scaring the [ __ ] out of me
the more you know you want a sip of this
and not only is he drinking the vodka
and whatever
but he's drinking and I'm not talking
about records in particular total amount
when I first started and work with other
comics that while they were drinking
they had a bottle and they were drinking
that they would do with drugs they
stopped the gamble and I'm like is this
what I want to be yeah I worked with a
guy that killed himself a couple years
but in 2000 he hung himself at the lab
stop hell yeah you remember that guy he
was he you they said the guy who really
really was gonna be a star but the drugs
he got deals this he was a star I met
him know I know you're talking about
I've been him in 93 and people were like
bro that dudes a badass comic drugs and
should just [ __ ] them up and I'm gonna
forget it was that was a situation he
took a bus in from Denver and I picked
him up somewhere in Boulder and from the
minute he got the car I was like alright
let's go for booze what are you talking
about we're professionals we talking
about you want to be a comedy want to be
a [ __ ] kid and next thing you know
we're at a [ __ ] drug house of Longmont
Colorado
at a park buying like coke from [ __ ]
people don't speak English is [ __ ] and
they were his friends and the next thing
you know we're driving to Fort Collins
and the next morning I had to get back
he called me at 8:00 in the morning to
drive an hour to join I went to a horse
track he was a degenerate horse guy and
I mean eight the morning he's already
doing blow with drinking popping pills
and telling me kid if you want to make
it in this business you better take a
[ __ ] pill you know and I'm like wow
okay all that [ __ ] is what I wanted to
see like from already in him yeah Artie
because people like that thumb really
though I didn't know that the show was
basically had been taking them as
christian-based and becoming a comic
yeah now it makes more sense to me yeah
that's a big part of that's hard that's
hard you know when you have to take
somebody away from their basic
fundamentals like I'm for being with
what's I read Lenny Bruce I knew this
wasn't gonna be a ladies gentlemen willy
Bruce we lived at the Chelsea Hotel
Aaron when I read that I knew what I was
getting myself into
yeah okay I'm gonna prepare myself but I
wanted a viewer at home so I'm gonna let
this and [ __ ] crazy comics out yeah
that you know they did that show on
Hannity about the dark side of comedy
they didn't come close now I remember I
remember when I started out I was a I
was an MC back then like I I came out of
Boston you know with Joe where we didn't
go on the road we had New England so we
went to New Hampshire one night the next
night we'd go down to East Providence
for an island next night you're in Maine
and never a hotel never a hotel you
drive three four hours get to a gig
sometimes they'd give you they give you
a check that may or may not bounce
because it's from out of state you get
back in the car you drive three or four
hours home again and and I remember I
finally said I want to go on the road I
want to go outside of this seat see if I
can do stuff around the country so I get
hooked up with this gig I Drive down me
and Tom Cotter you know Tom Cotter so we
got out we get in this car together and
we decide to drive down the east coast
from Boston down to Florida we're gonna
stop in every club on the way and we're
gonna we're gonna do five minutes set
we're gonna try to get into that club so
we spend like a week and a half two
weeks driving down the code
and I remember we did one room I think
was Charlotte North Carolina and the guy
booked a bunch of rooms the comedies
always out of their absolute what year
is this
this is 91 92 now somewhere around there
you just got the car
I like mitch hedberg well he do they
would try to Hogan right just got we
call back down there was this book that
came out and once a year and it was
called the comedy something it was a
directory of everybody comedy clothes in
the in the country and who booked it and
their address so you'd send your tape
back you'd make your half inch VCR tapes
you'd met you'd spend all your [ __ ]
money making 200 of these tapes you
spend all this money mailing them around
the country and then there's no
answering machines so you know no email
so you're calling you're calling these
Booker's meanwhile you got 500 other
comics all caught calling the st. Louis
and they got a stack of VHS is next
thick did next they're dusted they never
saw so we said [ __ ] it let's cut to the
chase we'll go there we'll get a
five-minute set we'll be in their face
we'll get some gigs so sure enough we
get some gigs out of this guy from North
Carolina Ron DiNunzio maybe we guy named
so they send me down my first my first
date is three weeks and it's gonna be
Jacksonville Florida the Bahamas and
then somewhere else in Florida I can't
remember but but my job is I got to pick
up this degenerate headliner first I got
to take him to Jacksonville and then
this guy had all these marching orders
because he lived he did he did so much
coke and did so much gambling that he
lived off his t-shirts after the show he
had t-shirts that had nothing to do with
his act it wasn't like a catchphrase
from his act nothin it was just like it
would just be like a t-shirt that said
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] and he'd have
stacks of him suitcases full of these
and it was down south and so he's
rednecks wits line up after the show and
they pull out their cash and he would
just have his pockets stuffed with $20
bills at the end of the night and then
he'd go buy blow and then go to the
casino I remember in the Bahamas every
night they would send me out I was the
emcee and so I would bring up the
feature act and sure enough this guy I'm
not gonna mention his name because he's
still out there and and they'd say go
find him
and I'd have to go find this guy and it
was on it was in the Bahamas and they
had a casino with the club so I've been
running around [ __ ] the craps tables
to the slot machines everywhere looking
for this
she's short guy was about five foot four
and he wore these glittery blazers like
real cheesy double-breasted cruise ship
with the black polyester pants with the
crease down the front and fancy shoes
shiny [ __ ] alligator skin shoes and
the hair we was like he looked like a
magician with that that hair was like
feathered back on the sides with the
hard part and and I'd go looking for
this guy and I'd have to drag come on
man you're on and [ __ ] [ __ ] every
night that feature act instead of doing
25 this guy was doing 30 35 40 minutes
waiting for me to find this guy and drag
him back to this show because he was
coked up in gambling and he'd come back
and he'd do his show and he was a pro
but he had this act you could tell he
been doing the same act for 20 years
word for word he just mailed it in he
got up there hit play and he was a
showman you know bigger than life play
to the back of the room little crowd
work same crowd work every time sir
where are you from blue oh I didn't know
they I don't know they made blank inland
and then after the show sell his [ __ ]
and then right back to the tables and on
Saturday night three shows on a Saturday
night all three shows tracking this
[ __ ] down to trying to get him
on stage so that feature I could stop
sucking his own dick out there burning
material he didn't have steel and by the
end doing anything just keeps stretching
it out until this guy got there that was
the hardest thing in the beginning was
meeting two headliners that were worse
people I was at the time yeah sure I was
a [ __ ] criminal of these guys yeah
but you knew you wanted to do these guys
had wives never cheat Yeah right just it
was just hot it was like two or three
years of meeting these tight on in those
D rooms that's what you me right those
triple rooms and all those other [ __ ]
little rooms you know beat him Joe
Rogan's not gonna go in there [ __ ] you
know Fitzsimmons is not gonna play those
rooms it's a [ __ ] B room you know you
work with the bottom of the barrel and
you like
and they borrow money from you they try
to borrow money from you the gam I mean
it's [ __ ] crazy so you're taking do I
even wanna [ __ ] do this yeah so
that's why I thought the RT character
but the Artic eric has been good to him
the RT character I'm very very good too
which is what you need to do those guys
VPN out you don't wanna like I was
watching the training daily add that he
makes ethan hawke get high in the car he
makes with smoke angel dust then he
[ __ ] with me [ __ ] that's evil stuff
yeah but that's part of it that's part
of the [ __ ] thing you gotta you know
we want you to build I think for a lot
of guests coming in here I think it's
like training day I think you're Denzel
Washington and you get people get people
some [ __ ] some gummy bears in him
some Chiba cheese that's it and Lucy
where three hours later they could they
come walking out into the parking lot
like what the [ __ ] just happened this is
so weird how my life is that I go
through phases and stuff the edibles I
loved because I think they really got
behind yeah me down but it also came
with a price of a [ __ ] bad appetite
and he was doing something to me and
like in February I started getting these
we first of all I couldn't eat half the
[ __ ] any more have to said that gummy
stuff has to be bad for you I mean it's
too strong I just mean the ingredients
one of them that we ate was like on a
list like something that caused kids oh
really
cushy cushy cushy so something happened
to be at one point that I was like I
gotta stop eat something was going to so
I have eliminated stuff of my diet but
you read that she had every day right I
would blast 250 milligrams
I got eleven in the morning be high like
wow what's a normal amount like 20 yeah
that's a lot for some people did we
cover the year do 2000 milligrams this
podcast I listen to and I love you guys
I love that you supported us over he is
but this podcast that I would not listen
to them we were just so [ __ ] hot I
know so we posted the P over mushroom
podcast today yeah I listened to that
can tell but it sounds crazy wait you
guys took mushrooms you sat in here and
did a power multiple times multiple
times
well he took acid with Ralphie a couple
times yeah one time we took acid with
Eddie Bravo Rory and how he took his
shirt off with everything it was [ __ ]
great it was great the duel pot you know
all these things are great but you gotta
move on and you gotta move on yeah and
this is in comedy this is whatever you
do you evolve and I find now that the
podcasts are a lot more entertaining
that would not do with the [ __ ]
animals yeah I don't need the edibles no
bro III liked it at the beginning is as
like a catch thing to let people know
that we're we're high and stuff now I'd
rather get the [ __ ] conversation on
the beat hey you listen to some of those
podcast and did it and it wasn't us it
was the guests some of the guests were
getting blasted and they come in here
trying to talk about something and
they'd be lost the last we will walk a
podcast he was in town he could even
talk yeah he couldn't we just sit there
with a beard and there's the next phase
like you can't put it up now there's
nothing to put up here you evolve in
your life if you don't evolve in your
life you're gonna [ __ ] die anyway
yeah I want to switch it up see you're
not doing acid or mushrooms anymore
either and I got everything I just got a
whole new batch of the shrooms
I got liquid acid I got tabs I got to do
window pane that they say and you're not
gonna use any of it this weekend in
Boston it's least first weekend of
obscene [ __ ] he's bringing me to a big
place you're gonna have a black he's
gotta pay his dues a little bit I just
yeah I'm gonna have to make them carry
luggage this week yeah run to the store
get milk but that's the wrong milk and
smack okay
you know Mike I'm MC a little bit just
so you know they can get your Gatorade
your passion your [ __ ] thumb even
drink I'll even drink that that week
you'll be commissioned he knows I
already got some from Al behind a big
dipper join it I spoke of his mother's
coming for the first show on Saturdays
yeah I'll be good I'll keep him legit
yeah
is out of the building it's all that's
right your Boston guy yeah well with
five joints per show this weekend we'll
go deep oh that's great great it's uh
like I've had to learn like the first
time mother say it was the second time I
did the store he I walk in he gives me
ten edibles and then he says oh yeah
Chappelle's going up and doing 30 in
front of you and lets me sit in that and
sweat for like 20 minutes like 30
minutes thinking I was gonna have to go
up after she listen if I tell you I'm
putting 400 pounds on the bar and pay
the lifted you're not gonna lift me you
never say I can't do it it's after you
do it there you go what the [ __ ] was
that I was three record you don't damn
yeah you know the same as would stand up
with you go give me a lot of eighteenth
[ __ ] about that my ass and you get up
there you know you've done 18 you've
done all your jokes you like yes give me
a light something's that right yeah and
you are you looking at me I'm weak huh
so that's what I'm worried about like
what I would get I'm getting nervous
like what if I don't see the light and
then I just get off thinking I missed it
and then you're like no I didn't give
you the light you set your timer to
vibrate on everyone about in your pocket
what about what they give you the light
can you get off with a tear you
should've got more yeah
dude I had it I had a beef with a
comment you won't get that let's show
this guy this guy was on I had I to show
one club and then I had another spot at
another club and it was tight I had to
get on and off and this guy's going on
head to me and and and he you know he's
an okay comic but he's going on and on
he gets the light gets the light again
and then he then he's got the ball sit
on the stool and go what else let's see
what else should we talk about and I'm
standing there missing my next set so I
go up to the light and I just start
flicking it me not the manager I'm
flicking it up and down and he gets all
pissed off comes off stage we got words
we [ __ ] scream at each other in front
of the whole club
we're just talking about of the a day I
see a light I wrap it up oh yeah I good
for I'm good for one minute after I say
yes that's it is huge by the world is
always a speck right well that's the
economic ruling the light on purpose
you're telling me you don't give a
[ __ ] the end of us - he's not part of
our yeah so that's good but I know that
I know that you're a selfish
[ __ ]
you know ya see a lot I get that workout
I can't wait to see that light you don't
got to like me twice yeah not at all
know what time when I was doing xanax in
Baba
I like didn't mean nothin just lay down
and think of it yeah they were white I
can't see the [ __ ] light but the
problem is a lot of times you got comics
that are used to headlining on the road
so they're doing the club when it says
do what you wanna do 45 to an hour and a
half II not an hour half but you know if
you want to do an hour and 15 they're
fine with it and then all sudden you're
told to do 12 or 15 minutes well you're
not headlining tonight you're doing 12
to 15 minutes that's it that's your job
and like you said there's other Peter
disrespecting everybody else on the show
and you don't get no excuse for it right
I don't care you used to do it through
hours it yeah don't call the story
they're gonna get off it Mattie you go
down the road soon that's the one thing
I like about you yeah that we're a lot
alike in the same way we like to give
the road a break yeah
it's that our bread and butter like I
think the road is a slow killer in a lot
of ways I think it's helpful at times
but then it becomes a time which the law
of diminishing returns so yeah I believe
we'd like to stay at home well yeah you
want to make sure that when you go out
it's exciting to you and it's not a
burden because then you're gonna have
better shows and I go out there I'm in
town I try a bunch of new [ __ ] you just
spits wind sprints that's what your sets
are in town you're doing wind sprints
and then you go out on the road and you
get to step those bits out a little bit
you get to you know feel what it's like
to control a crowd for an hour you know
and build it close strong all that [ __ ]
you don't really worry about in town you
know you work in town you spend you
could spend three four five minutes of
your 15 adjusting to the animal that
went on ahead of you before you even get
into your new [ __ ] and then you got to
close with something strong so that that
leaves you three or four minutes in the
middle to try new [ __ ] out
you go do an hour you can [ __ ] around
have some fun the crowd loves it they
love that you're experimenting a little
bit so yeah I got some day you want me
to read my dates yeah all right [ __ ]
what these guys to go see all right
Mohegan Sun in Connecticut October 4th
through the 6th and then I'm coming out
to Niagara Falls the Canada side the
comedy corner October 11 through 13 and
then private eats Providence Rhode
Island October 19 and 20 in and out
comedy connection doing that and then a
bunch of other dates after that San
Francisco punchline in November
then I'll go this is tour for you Grand
Rapids Michigan Portland Oregon all
through the fall then Christmas when do
you stop I don't stop I'll be in Nyack
New York December 28th through the 30th
oh and then 31st I'm up in Portland you
do Lewis yeah you are doing do you leave
that money on the table I don't drink
but do I care I'm not doing New Year's
yeah I'm doing lovely live December 28th
at but oh so you're coming I love that
room by the way yeah execute a favorite
[ __ ] great Itza yeah the pizza place
in town is phenomenal good people are
these food deliveries hotel [ __ ]
phenomenal the barbecue spot yeah take
your to this phenomenal right I still go
Monica's a kid cuz they'd serve you you
wait oh is that right oh yeah yeah not
very good yeah he's gotta that bad w
yeah I go up today I don't give a [ __ ]
how old you yeah you're seven [ __ ] it
that's a hot wheel
they got a valet for your hot wheel
[ __ ] over there is [ __ ] Greg I gotta
be honest with you the reason why we
have so much fun whether we doing your
show my show is the love of respect
absolutely have for you you're the
funniest guys the business you loose
this never any drama and you're always
welcome here
thanks brother I appreciate whatever
we're talking about [ __ ] yeah oh I talk
about and light being what you did today
that was yeah you know I look at my
daughter every day sometimes I go in
there and I dry her off but I always ask
anything happened at school today
somebody touch you weird or something
like that she's five and she was looking
to go yeah I can't leave the house so
she gets out of the shower
yeah cuz some playboy I have a couple to
go she wants you to dry off yeah and put
up the job as I just want to talk to you
I'll go with them while I'm dressing it
I've never touch her or whatever I'm
Tyler down yeah and they told her the
time I will draw you a little bumpy
offered you Buffalo try it's not my
bookie dad whatever I don't wanna touch
your [ __ ] I don't wanna be that
[ __ ] bad all right
oh I brush your hair who knows you could
be running for Supreme Court justice
well yeah I brought that [ __ ] comes back
that's nice that last lecture the hair
is the best think of the world yeah it's
so weird how I'm happy that I've taken
this plan and half of it I stole from
you because you we spoke about it at the
other spot about how important what it
was for you to raise your daughter and
your son you know I can't be a part of
their life you look at these kids from
comics and they're lost
yeah they're lost and they're daddy's
probably left for a million dollars and
that's great
yeah but they leave the thing that these
kids really needed you know why I sit
there sometimes at karate class I look
like why I'm gonna here [ __ ] an hour
and from here we got a little wine swim
for a mile yeah like why am I here it's
because this is it yeah this is what
most people give a hand for it Ralphie
could walk out of the grave right there
he would do this yeah don't [ __ ] the
road on a Wednesday yeah the bullet
karate classes or so thank you for
making me a better parent
well thanks man it can be aware of that
cuz I was little lost we'll have first
been our agent you know a mutual aid
yeah and you know I just went on the
road every week but I realized something
was missing
yeah and you told me what it was you
have to be a dad stay at home but [ __ ]
the road it's not about the money
yeah I wanted money I'm with I thought
it sold coke all right made millions of
dollars yeah no so thank you for yeah
thanks
that's nice you say dad yeah I'll be in
Boston it's sold out Harrigan the other
one is sold out but Florida I'm coming
down and I'm only coming for one [ __ ]
week to one place and that's West Palm
Beach so if you don't get your roller
skates in your cape on you're missing me
West Palm I'm tober 11th through the
13th and then I've been Cleveland the
25th through the 27th I want to thank my
man Greg Fitzsimmons for coming out I
love that guy with all my heart all the
respect if you listen to his podcast to
show you know the guy's the real deal I
want to thank you guys for listening and
number two I want to thank my family
over my bookie okay listen its bet the
season you and I both know it you took a
bath last week with New England you're
[ __ ] losing your fantasy you can't
pick a winner it's all gonna change
cause uncle Joey's on the direct you to
the right place my bookie is as
important as anything else because it's
not what you're betting on is who you're
betting with that's why I tell you
people to go to my bookie they're the
only service I recommend to the church
family that you know why cuz they're
good to me I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie
again you win and they pay it they got
in game live betting over nothing's on
fantasy port point scored and the most
rewarding player perks in the
[ __ ] business now my bookie is
slammed with new betters all day so they
want to give you everyone the best
service possible especially the church
family so if you're wanting to deposit
after 7:00 p.m. Eastern that's four
o'clock Pacific that's five o'clock
Colorado and so forth or so on don't
give you an additional $25 free play on
deposits over a yardstick that's on
allowance are you did you understand
when you said to you for join now and my
bookie will match your deposit dollar
for dollar use promo code Church to
activate the offer now you visit my
bookie online today it's my bookie m.y
Bo
kie and don't forget to use promo code
Church at the promo code we're creating
your account and you claim up to $1,000
in free play so if you're holding out so
after 4 o'clock today or up to 7 you get
next to $25 free play and using promo
code there's a tremendous game to
you got the [ __ ] Rams playing
the Minnesota white Queens on a [ __ ]
Thursday night who's better than you
guys right now if you want to hold on
till 7:00 you're gonna enter next to 25
out of free play by using promo code
Church all right it's up to you guys but
I'd wait till after dinner to make the
extra money my bookie you play you win
you get paid speaking of money you don't
beat the guys
I don't we're family we talk to each
other the right way Robin Hood I love
this I got the app down on my phone it's
an investment that don't let you buy and
sell stocks EF ETFs is options Kryptos
here's the beauty all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just the wealthy
people right guys like you and me values
of Robin Hood app are you ready are the
brokerages they charge up to $10 for
every trade but Robin Hood doesn't
charge a commission on fees trade stocks
that means you keep all your profits
it's easy to understand charts with
market data you place a trade just for
taps on your smartphone and the Robin
Hood web platform also lets you view
stock collections the most hundred
popular sectors like entertainment and
social media and curated categories like
female CEOs and analyst ratings of buy
hold and sell with every stock you learn
how to invest as you build your
portfolio discover new stocks and
tracked favorite companies with
personalized news feeds that's custom
notifications for price movements so you
know what you never miss the right move
to invest who's better than Robin Hood
nobody so I'm gonna do this thing you're
Robin Hood's gonna give the church
family a free stock like Apple for the
sprint to help build your portfolio you
sign up at church dot Robin Hood calm
again
that's church dot Robin Hood calm and
they're gonna give you a free stock
Apple Ford sprint something like that to
get the party started
who else does that for you uncle Joey so
I want to thank my bookie and I want to
thank Robin Hood for reaching out for
the church family for always hooking
this up I want to thank Greg I want to
thank [ __ ] Daniel O'Neill I want to
thank
you know me whenever the [ __ ] names I
want to thank the Christ killer but most
importantly I would thank the church
family for listening and for support
without you guys we'd have Oh God's how
either see you in Boston or October 11th
through the 13th in [ __ ] west
palm or the 25th of October to the 27
three Halloween weekend
bring the [ __ ] fireworks acid
bazookas we're going deep and hilarities
beside Dan I love your [ __ ]
thank you for marrying me and think
you've having my back all the time have
a great weekend stay black stay healthy
and we'll see you Monday morning tip top
and go kick this [ __ ] melee